i'm turning to austria now where
chancellor sebastian quartz has resigned
he's been under pressure over
allegations he bribed a newspaper for
favorable coverage prior to his election
as party leader and then chancellor as
he made that announcement on saturday
court said he wasn't involved in any
criminal activity and that he was
standing aside to prevent a government
crisis after his greens coalition
partner said he was unfit to lead the
country courts was expected to face a
vote of no confidence in parliament
later next week
after days of criticism kurtz finally
gave in
my country is more important to me than
i am
[Music]
and what it needs now is stability
so in order to break the current
stalemate
i want to make way to prevent chaos
and ensure stability
realized
the charges courts faces are serious
prosecutors suspect the finance ministry
used tax payer money to pay for
manipulated polling and positive media
coverage kurtz was already being
investigated for perjury in a separate
case he has denied any wrongdoing in
that investigation as well as the latest
allegations
days ago police raided kurtz's
conservative people's party headquarters
ramping up the pressure on him to step
down
kurtz will remain his party's leader in
parliament meaning he is likely to
continue calling the shots in austria's
governing coalition
[Music]
this is not about a single person but a
system of obsession with power
and we ask if this system shall remain
as parliamentary party leader kurtz
continues to hold the reins and keep the
power
kurtz has put forward foreign minister
alexander schallenberg as his proposed
successor
but even with kurtz out of the
chancellery the controversy that
surrounds him won't be going anywhere
dw correspondent fanny fascia is
covering the story for us from vienna
fanny how are austrians reacting to this
latest political scandal
people are quite surprised in fact that
chance of course stepped down as a
chancellor
but a lot of people are also
disappointed that he did step down from
that function but actually he stays in
power as a party leader and on top of
that he also wants to become the faction
leader the top lawmaker of his people's
party in parliament so having said that
there is a mixed emotion right now
people waking up right now to the
morning after this resignation but don't
really know what that means for austria
does it mean there's sort of like a
shadow government in place now
with the
possible new chancellor schallenberg the
current foreign minister actually to
take his office temporarily just for how
long how stable actually is this
government a lot of questions today in
austria but the bottom bottom line at
least for now with the resignation of
chancellor quartz or former chance of
course i should say now at least he
could prevent
the the entire coalition with the green
party from collapsing and bringing it
back basically from that bring of a
possible collapse tell us a bit more
about these corruption allegations that
have triggered this of course courts
denies these allegations but they have
triggered this scandal so if you could
just give us a bit more information on
them
basically this allegation stems back
from a time where chance of courts
wasn't even a chance that started in
2016 when he was still a minister but it
actually continued on to 2018 when he
was already a chancellor and briefly the
allegations are that of tax money was
paid for favorable media coverage but
also for some fake or twisted opposed
that would suggest that chancellor
quotes has a really good standing within
this country now chance of courts denies
any wrongdoing and he says in a system
in a democratic lawful system as austria
is people should wait for this
investigation come to an end before
making any judgment about him in fact he
said yesterday and that presser in that
resignation uh statement that he wants
to defuse all these allegations but on
top of that he's also under
investigation for perjury so clearly
there's a lot going on when it comes to
not just chancellor quotes but also a
lot of people around him as a result the
question really is just how clean or
cleaner the situation now is with chance
of course resigning but as i say just
stepping aside and not really completely
stepping down from the political scene
all right dw correspondent fanny facial
in vienna thanks very much
you